Based on the view of the people, the the
followers of Jesus.
>> Which people? The followers of Jesus.
Okay. What is the dominant view that
they've held, and they held even to this
day? Is it
>> is what which is very clear. That's the
reason I brought the topic. Yes,
according to the followers of Jesus,
believers of Jesus, and the laymen,
including the learned scholars, they all
say that Jesus did die on the cross. He
was buried in the grave. He lived He
stayed there for 3 days and 3 nights,
and then he rose from that, and he came,
and the prophecy was fulfilled. Awesome.
Okay, very good. I appreciate that. So,
now, the reason why that's important is
because this goes into the evidence that
I gave in my opening statement with the
Quran verses that says that Allah made
the followers of Jesus dominant in
spreading the message. And so,
therefore, since the dominant message is
that Jesus died and resurrected 3 days
later, either that's the belief that
Allah helped spread, and that's the true
message of Jesus, therefore making Islam
false cuz it contradicts that,
obviously. Or, that's the message of the
disbelievers, the disbelievers overcame
the true believers in spreading this
message that Jesus died and rose again,
and therefore Allah failed to keep his
promise in making the followers of Jesus
dominant, and so then Islam will be
false either way. You understand what
I'm saying?
>> me to do say this? Yes. Okay, that's
fine. So, you asked me about the
dominant view and objective the
Christians believe, and I said this is
what they believe. Yes, true. And now
you quote my verses from the Quran, and
you are saying that the dominant or the
message is what you believe. Where did
you get this from that we believe the
same what you believe? That's my point.
I I know that you don't believe what I
believe. My point is is that the Quran
says that the followers of Jesus are
made dominant over the disbelievers in
helping Jesus spread the message. So,
that would mean that the dominant
whatever the dominant message is
according to the Quran has to be the
true message that Allah helped spread.
If Allah
Yes, and the Quran says "Wama qataluhu
wama salabuhu and washbih lahum wama
qataluhu yaqinan." So this is the
dominant message which we are promoting
even to tell the Christians that this is
how we are helping this. Because you
can't take that message and put there
you know that verse and put your the
understanding to that because your
understanding is not there. It is
understood from your perspective, from
your understanding that that is the
message which you know we understood
that the Jesus did die. And Quran is
saying that if the the followers of
Jesus will be dominant with the message.
So that is you are putting that message,
that message of he was crucified, that
message that he was he died, that
message that he was buried, that message
he was raised. I have no problem. That
is from your perspective. But when you
talk about from that particular verse,
that verse does not say what is the
message. So so this is So this is where
the problem lies, doctor. It's that it
was it's by your own admission that the
dominant view among the followers of
Jesus is that he was crucified and rose
again on the third day. You admitted
that. And so
>> from your perspective. You have to
remember my word as well. No no cuz I I
I asked you
>> agreeing. I'm saying that it's how the
Christians No remember remember doctor.
I asked you Just really quick. I I asked
you I asked you apart from what I'm
showing you but but perspective my
perspective subjectively, yours, but
when we look at it objectively, what is
the dominant view amongst the followers
of Jesus regarding uh the crucifixion?
Is it that he didn't die or was it that
he did die? And you acknowledge that
yes, to the followers of Jesus, to the
Christians, the dominant view is
absolutely that he died, was buried, and
rose again. So,
>> now. I again say it from according to
the followers of Jesus.
>> I know. So, yeah. So, according to the
followers of Jesus, the message is that
Jesus died by crucifixion, was buried in
the tomb, rose again 3 days later. And
so, since that's the view and the
message of the followers of Jesus, Allah
says in chapter 61 verse 14 and 355 that
he's going to make that he made the
followers of Jesus dominant over the
disbelievers in helping Jesus spread his
message. And so, if he makes them
dominant in spreading the message, that
means that there's they're truly
spreading the message of Jesus. And we
see that this included the death,
burial, and resurrection. So, the
problem is is that the Quran obviously
like you keep repeating, correctly. The
Quran says it was made to appear so.
They neither killed him nor did they
crucify him, but it was made to appear
so. But, the followers of Jesus was
going around saying Jesus died by
crucifixion, was buried in a tomb, and
rose again 3 days later. So, the problem
is is that Allah denies he denies the
crucifixion while pushing the message of
the crucifixion. There's a dilemma
there. So, either the crucifixion is the
true message that Allah helped spread
and therefore Allah's contradicting
himself by saying it would it didn't
happen. Or, the message of the
crucifixion was spread by disbelievers
and that became dominant over the true
believers, which would then make Allah a
failure because he said he'll make the
true believers of Jesus dominant over
the disbelievers. So, that's the
dilemma. Quran speaks about the Injil.
Quran does not speak about the Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John. What is the Injil?
What is the Injil? I'm asking you. No,
you're not. You're saying that what
you're saying that Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John is not the Injil. So, tell us
what it is then.
>> Yes, it is it is the Gospel of Matthew,
Gospel of Mark, Gospel of John, Gospel
of Luke. Where's the Gospel of Jesus?
Okay. So, when we do this, you guys can
still see the screen, right?
Yes.
>> Yep. Okay. So, if we do this, the
beginning of the Gospel of Jesus Christ,
the son of God. That's how Mark starts
off. So, it's not his own Gospel. He's
recording the Gospel of Jesus. Yeah, was
it approved by Jesus? Was it approved by
Jesus? Jesus says that I sent you
prophets and scribes. So, when when
Jesus when hold on when Mark says that
he's writing when Mark says he's writing
the Gospel write that in front of him?
This ain't John. This is Mark. When when
Mark is saying that he's writing the
Gospel, he's writing the Injil. Is he
right or is he wrong?
When did he start writing? It doesn't
matter.
It matters. Why? It matters. Why? When
when was the Injil The person The person
who has already gone for 20 years away
and then somebody comes and writes about
his saying. I'm just giving you 20 of
years or 20 months. I'm not giving you
exact date because there are so many
other informations are there that the
Bible start being written by Paul, John,
Mark, Matthew or that. When was the
Injil written?
Injil was not written. That's what I'm
saying. Where is the Injil We believe.
Come on, man. Hold on, let me show you.
So, this is chapter 7 verse 1:57.
Yes. Those who follow the messenger the
prophet who can neither read or write.
I'm going to skip the brackets cuz
that's not in the actual verse, even
though it it kind of helps me. But, I'm
going to skip that just to be fair to
the actual Quran, okay?
Uh who can neither read nor write
whom they find written
with them in the Torah
and the Injil. So, the Quran says that
the Torah and the Injil are written down
and they're with the Jews and the
Christians in Muhammad's time. Do you
understand what I'm saying? So, the
Injil was written according to the
Quran.
The question now is when was it written?
You bring me the Injil of Jesus of Jesus
prophet's time. Brother, when was it
when was the Injil written?
I'm telling you it wasn't written
written. The Injil of Jesus was not
written the time when he was raised.
>> Sure.
Sure. When was it written is my
question. When was it written? Mhm. It
was written when Jesus was preaching
them. Okay, can you show me where your
Quran says that the Injil was being
written down while Jesus was preaching?
>> Because the Injil was given to him. So,
it was during his time. Yeah, but where
does it say it was Where does it say it
was written in his time? Like, for
example, you believe that the Quran was
compiled. You believe the Quran was is a
is a was compiled, right? But, it wasn't
compiled by Muhammad. Muhammad That was
compiled after Muhammad, right? No. No.
No. Who said so? Who said so? Bukhari.
Abu Bakr Abu Bakr had a Zayd ibn Thabit.
>> have a Can a separate debate on this? I
challenge you then. On whether or not
the Quran was compiled after Muhammad.
>> of the Quran. No. No. We can have that
debate. But, academically. Sure. Okay,
let's come back to this point now.
>> Yes. So, So, where So, where does the
Quran say it
No. No. No. Where does it say it was
written in his time? The Injil of
Matthew. Where does Quran say the Injil
of
>> claims that. Again, I showed you where
what Mark says. Mark doesn't say he's
writing his own Quran. No. No. No. He
stick with the Injil of Jesus. Doctor,
excuse me. I showed you Mark. He doesn't
say this is the Gospel of Mark. He says
this is the Gospel of Jesus, the son of
God. So, that's what Mark claims that
he's writing. You're saying that Mark
isn't writing the Injil, the Gospel of
Jesus. And you're saying that it's
because Mark wrote this after Jesus
ascended. So, this is why the relevant
question. The Quran says the Injil was
written. When was the Injil written?
Okay, it is relevant. My My son, tell
me, if the
Gospel of Jesus was existing, then why
John has to write it? Did the Quran
exist in Muhammad's time?
Yes. Did scribes write it down?
Habibi. Habibi. I'm telling you don't
jump here and there. I'm using your own
logic. I'm using your logic to show you
how it backfired. No. No. I'm not I'm
not saying. I'm just asking you that if
the Jesus Injil was there, then why
Mark, Matthew, John, and Luke have to
write the gospel. Because it was verbal.
It wasn't written down yet.
So that means Jesus didn't give them
anything in writing, yes?
>> He didn't give them anything in writing.
And he went. He left. Do you have
something to suggest otherwise?
Yeah, no, no. He left. Okay? Okay. So
when was the Injil written down? Now you
brought me this verse. It says written.
Yeah. Written where? It says the Injil
was written. The my question to you is
when was it written?
>> you are saying
it was verbal. Just now you said. Oh my
gosh. Dude, just like how the Quran
started off as a verbal recitation, so
the Injil is a verbal recitation and
ends up getting written down after it's
verbally recited. Just like the Quran.
If you have a problem with that, show me
otherwise. When was the Injil written
down? Tell me.
No,
I'm just asking you when when Injil is
saying the Quran is saying the Injil was
written. Mhm. So then why Mark had to
write another Injil? He's not writing
another Injil. He's writing the Injil.
The the whose Injil is that? Jesus's.
Who confirmed that? All the apostles.
Mark is writing the gospel. He's writing
the Injil. Okay. Okay. If this is your
belief, I respect that. No, but but it's
not but you're saying you're denying it.
What I'm denying it because I'm Muslim.
I know. Just hold on a second, doctor.
Doctor, 1 second, please. I understand
your belief as a Muslim. Trust me. You
I know what you believe. My issue with
you is that you have no substance for
why you believe what you believe. You
have no plausible reason to deny that
Mark is writing the Injil. Nothing. No,
I don't have to. I love it.
I love it. I say good luck to the
Christians. They should follow word to
word, by word, verse by verse of
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John. I say
that.
>> So So you agree that Mark is writing the
Injil? His Injil. No.
Let's Let's do this again. You see the
You see the verse on the screen, right?
Yes. All right. This is what Mark says.
This is the beginning of the Gospel of
Jesus Christ, not of Mark, of Jesus
Christ. So, Mark is claiming to write
the Injil of Jesus. Is Do you agree with
Mark here or do you disagree? And why?
Okay. Let's understand this. If Mark is
writing the Jesus Gospel, then what did
Matthew write?
>> Brother, do you disagree? Focus on Mark.
Do you disagree that he I am I am
focusing on Mark. I said, "Okay, Mark is
writing the Gospel of Jesus." Also. What
did Mark write? Matthew write? Forget
Forget Matthew and them. This is strong
enough for me. We can get to Matthew and
them in a second. So, Mark is writing
the Injil. Awesome. So, we have the
Injil and according to the Injil, guess
what Jesus says in the Injil. What does
he say? Watch what Jesus says in the
Injil. See?
"We are going up to Jerusalem and the
Son of Man will be delivered over to the
chief priests and the scribes and they
will condemn him to death and deliver
him over to the Gentiles and they will
mock him and spit on him and flog him
and kill him and after 3 days he will
rise." So, according to the Injil, Jesus
taught that he will die and rise again,
which falsifies Islam and makes
Christianity true.
Good.
Well done. You won the case. Thank you.
I appreciate it. You won the case. Now,
let's go to Matthew. Bring the same
thing.
Okay, so the debate's over.
The debate's over now. You can see the
debate.